-Welcome back to the show,
Bashir, it's always good
to see you, buddy.
-Nice to see you, too, Jimmy.
It's nice to be here.
-I brought this up once before
when you were on the show,
but you were a writer
on "Late Night."
-"Late Night with Jimmy Fallon."
-For four years.
-Great TV show,
just really solid writing.
-I mean, yeah,
the writing was solid.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah. We had you --
-The host was great, too.
Loved him.
-We had you perform, as well,
because, you know --
-Yeah, I did a few characters.
-Yeah.
-A few bits.
-A few bits and skits.
-Bits and skits.
-Now you're co-starring with --
-[ Laughs ]
-You looked at the photo.
Now you're co-starring
with Tom Cruise.
But before you co-starred
in "Top Gun" with Tom Cruise,
you were playing
Weird Al --
Weird Al Roker.
-There it is.
-Is what we did on our show.
That was Weird Al.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Do people come up to you
and do any of the bits like...?
-Yeah, still, every now and
then, I'll be like at CVS
about to get some toothpaste.
I'll reach for the tube,
somebody else reach
at the same time,
our eyes will meet
and he'll be like,
"Hubble gotchu."
[ Laughter ]
-Hubble gotchu!
Milky J, man. That was my jam.
-Yeah, man. Still got fans.
They love it.
-Your writing partner,
Diallo --
-Diallo Riddle.
I love him.
Please give him my best.
-I will, I will.
-You guys met at Harvard.
-We did. We did.
Yeah, we met at Harvard.
In a writing thing or...?
-No, we met in
an a cappella group.
It was...
It was a bunch of brothers,
and we all went to Harvard
and we wanted to have
a good name.
So we put our Harvard
brains together
and we came up with...
Brothers.
[ Laughter ]
-Brothers was the name?
-Brothers. Yeah.
-Wow, you really put
some thought into that.
-Then we sort of was like,
"Man, I think
we should do better than that."
We were like, "Nah, that's good,
man. Let it happen."
-Brothers.
-Let it play. Yeah.
-What would Brothers do?
-So we would do, like, Shai.
You know, we'd go out to like,
you know, the T stops
in Boston singing for, like,
a random dude playing
the pan flute
and the lost MIT student.
[ Laughter ]
-You would do Shai?
-Oh, we would sing Shai, man.
-"If I ever fall"...
-Oh, you know it?
-I know, I know it, yeah.
-You guys want to hear
a little taste of that, maybe?
-Wait, here. You want a...?
-Oh! Oh, good. A microphone.
-We always have one.
Wait, wait.
What's the note gonna be like?
-♪ Mmmmm, mm-mm, mm-mm-mm-mmmm ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Two, three!
-♪ The very first time
that I saw your brown eyes ♪
♪ Your lips said hello,
and I said hi ♪
♪ I knew right then
you were the one ♪
♪ But I was caught up ♪
-♪ Caught up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I was caught up ♪
♪ Caught up ♪
-♪ I was ♪
-♪ Caught up ♪
-Alright.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a new -- that's
a follow-up song.
"I Was Caught Up."
-"I Was Caught Up," yeah.
-Let's talk about
"Top Gun: Maverick."
-Crazy. Crazy.
-You got the call
that you're going to be
in "Top Gun."
-Yeah, I was with my mom
and my sister.
I went to the museum,
Art Institute in Chicago.
Folks might know it
from "Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
It's the museum where
he was in that scene.
And I got the call.
All of a sudden my mom
is jumping up and down,
my sister, we're high fiving,
and everybody in the museum
was like,
"Damn, they love Picasso."
[ Laughter ]
-"Look at that."
-"Look at these guys," yeah.
-They were like, "Hey!
Cubism, right, bruh? Yeah!"
-He's getting hype over art!
-Getting hype over
the brushstrokes.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, it was unbelievable.
-We had a screening for
our office
and saw it on IMAX,
which I recommend --
it's just the sound, the visual.
-Gotta see -- yeah.
-And you are in every scene
with Tom Cruise, bud.
You're in the first scene.
Dude, you play Hondo.
-Yeah.
-And let me tell you something,
I wish we videotaped
our reaction
'cause you came on
and we all just went nuts,
like, "Aah! Bashir!"
We're going crazy.
And we have a couple
of new people here
and they're like,
"Why are you freaking out?"
-"You guys are going crazy
for THAT guy?"
[ Laughter ]
"You know Tom Cruise
is up there, too, right?"
-Yeah. No.
-"No, we know him, though!"
-You got more applause
and screams.
And you're funny
and you're just awesome in it.
Did you guys bond,
you and Tom Cruise?
-Oh, man. That's -- he just
texted me yesterday
just 'cause we had a screening.
I feel like I'm bragging
and it's not even --
I'm just telling a --
-No, no, no brag.
-He texted me yesterday.
It's interesting.
And, you know,
we had a screening
in my hometown of Chicago.
And he was like,
"How's your family and friends?
Did everybody love the movie?
Was it great?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, they loved it."
We would talk about
that stuff on set.
That's actually how we kind
of built camaraderie.
When the cameras weren't
rolling, we would just talk.
We talked about -- he shot
"The Color of Money"
with Paul Newman in Chicago.
It's one of his favorite cities.
I told him about my show,
"South Side."
He was like, "I want to see it."
And, you know,
for those of you who, you know,
Hollywood people,
when they say stuff,
usually it's like, "Yeah,
you don't mean that," you know?
You're just throwing words
at the universe, right?
And then two weeks later,
I get an email, he's like,
"Oh, what's up, man?
I thought you were going to
send me that thing
so I can look at it."
I was like,
"Oh, I better do this."
And so I sent it to him.
He loved it.
He ended up
calling our writer room,
telling him all the jokes
he liked,
all his favorite bits,
his favorite actors.
And I'm like, "Hey, guys, uh,
Tom Cruise wants
to talk to you."
They were going crazy.
So, yeah.
-He's just legit, right?
-He's legit, man. Yeah.
-Yeah.
We love you, Tom Cruise.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
We're showing a clip
from your movie.
-Let's do it. Let's show a clip
from "Top Gun: Maverick."
-Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Door bangs ]
-Admiral.
Uh, just in time, sir.
-I'm early. So are you.
Care to explain?
-Uh, Mav, Admiral Cain
is asking --
-Ordering.
-...ordering that we
bring her down.
-[ Speech breaking up ]
[ Speaking gibberish haltingly ]
-This is where we've had trouble
with comms, sir.
It's the Earth's curvature.
Yeah, it's called Earth bulge.
Did anyone offer you a coffee?
Okay.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah!
Bashir Salahuddin!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Top Gun: Maverick"
is in theaters,
Dolby Cinema and IMAX now.